مرحبا بكم مشاهدينا في مجزيل قال وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي ان ايران تخوض حرب
استنزاف ضد اسرائيل بوكلائها القريبين عبر
الحدود اضف جلانت ان ايران حولت سفن
تجاريه الى معسكرات عائمه للارهاب في
مسارات الملاحه البحريه حسب تعبيره في
المقابل قال مسؤول ايراني الجزيره ان اي
اعتداء عسكري على المنشات النوويه سيقابل
برد واسع وغير مسبوقا اضافانا تخصيب
اليورانيوم يجري عند عتبه الستين في المئه
وان كلام اسرائيل مجرد تحريض ودعايه
قد نفذ امس مناوره ميدانيه تضمنت محاكاه
لعمليه اسر جنود استراليين واقتحام
مستوطنه اسرائيليه وعبوري مئات المقاتلين
الحدود استعراض اسراب من الطائرات المسيره
وقصفها لمواقع اسرائيليه
في تركيا اعلن المرشح الرئاسي السابق سنان
اوغان انه سيدعم مرشح تحالف الجمهور
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان في جوله الاعاده
واكد اوغان انه لم يدخل في مساوات او
تعهدات خلال اللقاءات مع المرشحين
الرئاسيين
وقال الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان انه لم يخوض
اي مفاوضات مع السنان اوغلو واعرب عن امله
ان صوت الشعب التركي له بكثافه وان يحصل
على رقم قياسي من الاصوات في جوله الاعاده
واضف اردوغان انه لا يمكن الوثوق بمنافسه
كمال الذي قال انه يمارس الضغط والترهيبه
والابتزازه ضد خصومه
في المقابل لا قال مرشح وتحالف الشعب كمال
انه بات من الواضح من يقف الى صف الوطن
ومن يقف الى جانب من يبيعه واضاف ان
تحالفه قادم لانقاذ تركيا من الارهاب ومن
اللاجئين حسب تعبيره
السودان دخلت الهدنه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع حيز التنفيذ وقالت الخارجيه
الامريكيه ان الاتفاق سيخضع لمراقبه دوليه
لاول مره من قبل وسطاء التفاوض وكانت
العاصمه الخرطوم شهدت قبل ذلك معارك ضاريه
وتحليقا مكثفا لطائرات المقاتله كما
اندلعت اشتباكات بين الطرفين في مواقع
مختلفه من العاصمه
جانبه قال المبعوث الاموي الخاص الى
السودان ان القتال في السودان مستمر رغم
التزام الجانبين بعدم السعي لتحقيق مكاسب
عسكريه قبل سريان وقف اطلاق النار
قال المتحدث باسم المخابرات الاوكرانيه ان
فيلقين روسيين معارضين ينفذين عمليه داخل
الروسيه لانشاء منطقه امنيه لحمايه
المدنيين الاوكرانيين
في المقابل اعلن حاكم مقاطعه بيلغرود
الروسيه ان ثمانيه اشخاص اصيبوا جراء هجوم
نفذته مجموعه اوكرانيه على المقاطعه وشارك
غلاد كوف الى الدفع بقوات خاصه بالتزامن
مع عمليه اجلاء من المنطقه
يشاهد انتهى هذا المنجز في
[موسيقى]